il faut en parler nous sommes avec eux
temir porras ancien conseiller de hugo
chavez est actuellement professeur à
sciences po paris bonjour temir porras
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france on le disait roy noyer doit donc
appelé l'opposition à boycotter ce
scrutin
pourquoi cet appel en premier lieu c'est
une partie de l'opposition certainement
les parties de dominos qui ont
d'accompagner willow dans l'aventuré
vous allez répondre c'est l'histoire qui
s'abstiennent et qui appelle d'ascension
mais les partis d'opposition qu'on
appellera un modéré ou nationalistes se
sont participe tout de même aux
élections l'opposition est divisée sur
ce scrutin et monsieur guido dont la
légitimité en tout cas la l'agité du
discours venais justement de son
élection il ya deux ans comme président
de l'assemblée nationale et donc à
partir de cette interprétation la setil
qu'il a pris il a donné elle pas de
s'autoproclamer président de la
république justement en disparaissant
cette assemblée nationale avec les
nouvelles élections puisque vous venez
de l'armée line assemblée nationale et 5
en bas puisqu'il ne participe pas aux
élections
justement son sa légitimité ou en tout
cas la dignité qu'il a essayé de se
donner
depuis l'assemblée nationale disparaît
d'où justement le fait qu'il ne
participe pas aux élections qui les
contestent implique encore une fois les
juridiquement la justification de son
entreprise depuis 2010 ne disparaît avec
ses avec l'installation de cette
nouvelle assemblée nationale à partir du
mois de janvier
alors du coup si la majorité est
certaine de voir ces élections tourné en
sa faveur
qu'est ce qui pourrait changer dans le
pays est ce que ça va changer quelque
chose au fond on appelait première chose
c'est que rien n'est joué d'avancé même
si encore une fois il y a de fortes
chances que la majorité présidentielle
à peine la victoire et la majorité
absolue dans la nouvelle assemblée est
il faut rappeler aussi que cette
majorité là est elle même divisée
il ya il y a une la gauche de la
coalition présidentielle qui se présente
de façon indépendante et puis je dirais
un groupe de partis d'opposition du
centre du centre gauche qui eux aussi
pris sept matches il faudrait attendre
des résultats et ce qui change
fondamentalement c'est que le venezuela
malgré ces circonstances tout à fait
exceptionnelles retrouvera au moins de
janvier puisque la nouvelle assemblée
s'installera à partir du 5 janvier et
une certaine normalité institutionnelle
il faut il faut savoir que voilà on vit
une période de deux ans de quasi
sécession du pouvoir de partition du
pouvoir d'état et maintenant on aura à
partir de janvier une assemblée
nationale et un pouvoir exécutif qui ne
seront plus en conflit institutionnel
qui ne seront plus longs conflits en
défiance l'un l'autre
indépendamment de la composition que le
gouvernement et une majorité ou pas donc
en interne le venezuela retrouve fort
heureusement une certaine normalité
institutionnelle on pourra voter la loi
on pourra voter le budget on pourra
débattre de la politique interne puisque
vous avez souligné c'est un pays qui
traverse une crise une crise immense
donc il faut trouver des solutions est
ce qui n'a pas été possible pendant la
mandature précédente
orange qui ne sera pas résolue c'est le
sait le contentieux international qui
disent qui oppose le venezuela est
principalement les états unis des pays
de l'union européenne et d'autres pays
latino américains mais principalement
les états unis puisque ne reconnaissons
pas ces élections et c'est la légitimité
de cette assemblée nationale les états
unis continueront d'appliquer
la clr politique de sanction qui a été
mise en place par donald trump mais qui
a un appui bipartisans comme on dit aux
états unis et dont l'objectif est le
fait que les américains appellent le
changement de régime
il faut maintenant encore une fois les
circonstances changent il y as byden
maison blanche mais la politique de
sanctions resteraient en place et le
venezuela sera fortement limitée dans sa
capacité économique et financière
internationale de et essayer de
retrouver une certaine normalité
économique et du coup alors dans ce
contexte là quel avenir pour nos rois
noyés d'eau il est bien compromis un peu
à l'image de cette assemblée nationale
en interne pour wang wei le ou les
groupes d'opposition qu'on appelle le g4
donc les quatre partis principaux
d'opposition la leçon du passé et qu'à
chaque fois que l'opposition s'est
retiré du jeu institutionnel puisque il
a essayé l'opposition essayé pendant les
deux dernières années de déloger le
président du pouvoir de accompagner
cette politique de changement de régime
donc s'est abstenu de participer dans la
politique institutionnelle en 2005
l'opposition a commis la même erreur à
l'époque face au président chavez et ça
lui a coûté des années de traversée du
désert puisque qu'une fois
indépendamment des conditions politiques
internes du pays le fait de ne pas
participer de ne pas voir de
représentation de ne pas en appeler au
vote populaire la marginalise dans le
cas de juan willow sur leadership était
déjà et rose violet il a hérité par set
cette incapacité à parvenir à ses fins
de remplacer nicolas spadois à la
présidence mais maintenant n'ayant plus
la légitimité de l'assemblée nationale
et n'ayant pas encore une fois le vote
populaire
comme source de légitimité et bien son
origine est bien incertaine il
semblerait que la seule existence de
boyaux et de son gouvernement soit c'est
une sorte de gouvernement en exil
appuyé par les états unis pour combien
de temps il faudra voir avec
l'administration baden mais il reste
cantonné marginalisés si nombreux à
cette sphère internationale
oui reconnaissance de certains pays et
incapacités si vous voulez d'avoir une
incidence sur la politique intérieure de
son pays
merci beaucoup il tenir porras pour
votre éclairage rappelle que vous êtes
ancien ancien conseiller de hugo chavez
est actuellement professeur à sciences
po paris